so i don't know if you've heard um but
the kelly clarkson show uh we won a few
minutes this year okay we are very
excited about it we're a young show and
it's a really cool thing to
have your work validated people digging
what you're doing and so i was so
excited because they came in a couple of
them came in
and this is for host and for show right
and we're like so excited i'm just like
oh my gosh this is so amazing and then
i'm even more excited because then i
noticed it says the 2020 2021
sports emmy awards
are you serious like
i didn't just win
one sports emmy
i won
dough sports emmys
two
like i get it because
you know i drink some white on this show
it's like a
it's a bicep curl it's like some action
there's some sports action some
athleisure also i've done some karate on
this show and some dancing
um with a pole at that and that's hard
okay for mama that was that was athletic
okay but i'm pretty sure also um
there's never been a daytime show to win
sports emmy so
the emmys are cool
okay john legend we see you you got
winner but are you a seaguar winner do
you have a sports emmy or two just like
laying around cause i do it's pretty
cool we're just we're pioneers here at
the kelly clarkson show um i feel like
i'm basically gonna
celebrate this achievement
like any sports emmy winning gal would
do from texas so let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
emmy winner
guys guys i'd like to take this minute
before i dive into that hot dog to say
thank you for the assists
the great passes just all the great
plays
that we've experienced and we're just a
really great team and i just want to
thank you
because of you we are sports and winners
you know what let's go make some more
sports emmy winning tv people let's do
it
[Applause]
she knows it's a mistake right i just
let her have it
[Applause]
[Music]
would you like to hold that it's heavy
i don't know if i can hold that yeah you
know what i've got it i've got it's a
lot of weight it's a lot of weight to
carry i got it i'll carry the burden
[Music]
you